[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in ryan fitzpatrick who uh
just announced his retirement and
he are you officially retired like
retired retired sent in your paperwork
uh i'm gonna have to check on the
paperwork stuff but i i'm officially in
my mind retired yes but is there
paperwork that you actually have to fill
out
and you send it to the nfl home office
gosh that is a great question and i feel
embarrassed that i do not know i don't
think so though i don't think i need to
send anything in could you have played
another
season uh
i'm not sure i mean my i had a hip
injury last year that you know still
gives me some issues every now and again
um so
i don't know physically mentally
emotionally yes totally could have
played but i'm not sure physically if i
would have been able to get there
is there a hit that you remember that
still hurts
yes uh there are two hits that still
hurt every time i get out of bed
um
james harrison and london fletcher were
the two guys both like similar in
stature the kind of shorter compact
but real heavy hitters and
the london fletcher one i slid the line
the wrong way and never made that
mistake again i was wondering about this
with josh allen that he's sort of a
unicorn he's maybe he's
cam newton 2.0
maybe a better passer but
i don't know if you get to the point
where you say i don't want to take away
one of his great weapons now as an
analyst and you played the position
what would you say to josh allen i mean
you want to preserve yourself but also i
don't want to take away that weapon so
there's sort of that dichotomy of
can you do it how long do you do it how
much should you do it
yeah and that it was just funny
listening to collinsworth last night
wrestle with that the whole game but
that
is what makes him
special like his ability to run it's the
designed runs it's on third down when
they're in certain coverages him
recognizing that and taking off but more
so than that and the picking up the
first downs and the the five 10 15 yard
runs
if you look at the sideline if you look
at his teammates every time he's on the
ground you've got two people helping him
up
he's got a big goofy smile on his face
that energizes that football team and i
think that's something that's hard to
quantify we can't go into the analytics
of how excited people get to watch josh
allen play football but it energizes
obviously the city of buffalo but that
sideline and the defense and the guys
that he's playing with so i think it's
such an important part of his game
because of what it brings to the team
not just because of the first downs that
he's picking up but also with cam newton
i just felt like i
you don't want your quarterback to run
as you know i don't care how fast you
are or how big you are somebody's going
to be faster and somebody's going to be
bigger and you're going to be get hit i
i liken josh allen almost to dante
culpepper like these guys were just big
and athletic but then culpepper ended up
having the knee injury i don't know how
you protect a quarterback
can you who has that kind of athleticism
no i don't i don't think you can and i
think he's really smart about picking
and choosing you know he's
he's got a great stiff arm we saw that
on display last night
he's not gonna try to
run over uh well maybe he did try to run
over bobby wagner but you know there's
there's certain guys he's not going to
try to run over ray lewis um you know
he's going to pick and choose his
battles but uh it's what makes him
maybe more special than any other
quarterback in the league
did you ever try to run over somebody
you like you get caught up with
adrenaline and you're like i'm gonna
take this guy on
yeah i mean i the best one i had was
actually
i think i was in year
13 of my career and it was a pre-season
game and i just got caught up in it i
was in maybe the year 14 or 15. i was in
miami we're playing tampa pre-season and
uh
it was pre-season and it was my buddy
jack stitchy um but sometimes it just
takes over you got you're out there
playing football
if i didn't see the game last night
how would you sum up the rams
performance
they laid an egg i mean they
they didn't play very well
buffalo had
four turnovers and still scored 31
points but
more so than the defensive performance
it was the offensive performance for me
that was concerning i think you could
tell early on
mcveigh by the way he was calling plays
he wanted to protect the offensive line
they were going to run the ball they
threw a couple you know the tight end
screens and they
they ended up giving up seven sacks uh i
don't know it wasn't that allen robinson
wasn't
a big factor in the game he was
he didn't even get any targets um so
that was their big acquisition and he
didn't even
get a target he didn't get a wide
receiver screen they didn't try to get
them going at all so
i think there's you know some alarms
that are sounding right now
on you know alan robinson and that
relationship maybe with matt stafford
and their dynamic and chemistry
it just didn't seem like he was looking
at him at all and that's a very
important position to get that offense
to go this year he's ryan fitzpatrick
amazon prime video thursday night
football analyst and of course former
nfl quarterback but can you look at this
as a one-off with the rams
or did you see something that is going
to be concerning
well i think
you know i was more concerned with their
offense and their defense and
sean mcvay's their head coach and
matthew stafford is their quarterback so
um
you know i i don't know if this happens
two three four weeks in a row yes we're
going to be really concerned but my
biggest concern coming out of it was
the lack
of
opportunities for alan robinson and not
even really looking his way even even
sometimes when the coverage dictated it
um so i just wonder about that chemistry
because it is such an important position
in that offense
how much did your education play in in
processing or not play in to processing
you know week in and week out playing in
the nfl at quarterback
uh
i you know i don't i don't know that it
i don't know that it did i know early on
i picked one of the only professions
where it worked against me you know well
i don't know this guy he went to harvard
does he really care about football that
was kind of the question i got all the
time
um
i don't know that it played in much but
you know having to go from city to city
learning different offenses um
that was that was always a big thing and
a big strength of mine was to be able to
pick those up quickly
you have all your jerseys framed
i have all my jerseys i don't have them
framed right now i've got a in my office
here at our house i've got all the
helmets and then i have game balls with
my kids names
and their stats you know height weight
the day that they were born and what
city they were born in
best and worst uniform you played in
uh
well i played in the i played in the
christmas game when the jets were all
green and the bills were all red and
that one
that one was
the uniform was fine i guess but the
combination was just a little bit weird
um i think the early rams uniform
that i was in back in 0.506 those were
those were a little bit tough and then
the throwback miami maybe the
throwback bills
those were pretty cool
i know you have a lot of people there to
help you with amazon but do you have any
questions that i might be able to help
you in being an analyst
on thursday night football
uh
you know i i do have a lot of opinions
coming my way for people to tell me what
to do and what not to do but um you know
my
really my biggest question and the thing
that i wonder how it's going to go is
still not sure i have so many
relationships
coaches players gm's staff
you know the part about
where do i draw the line of information
i'm getting things that i'm saying on
air i'm not saying betraying trust
that trust issue for me is one of those
things that i'm not really sure where
that line is going to be
i think what you have to do is just be
fair
because you don't want to be
so vanilla that you're not interesting
but you don't want to be over the top
where you're compromising relationships
but i think yeah and i work with tony
dungy and rodney harrison i've worked
with a lot of analysts over the years
and i always said just be honest like be
no nobody can fault you for being honest
now that doesn't mean you have to be
honest about something that maybe you
shouldn't be putting on tv but you're
going to get so much advice
that trying to filter that out and go
can i trust one person who will give me
the best advice and that's that's what
you should try to do because somebody's
going to say hey do this hey don't do
this you know what worked is this
it has to work for you
and everybody's different but i always
thought that the less i i've cluttered
your head with
the better
and
and
you know i would probably button the
shirt up a little bit not show as much
chest hair as you can
i actually was going to go one more down
okay so let's see let's see yeah okay
nah
i should brush it i think
more chest hair than less chest hair but
you're also speaking in sound bites
you're going to have
20 seconds
40 seconds
they may say hey cut it short
and that's what's going to be difficult
can you get to the point
can you deliver the knockout punch i
would always say that to my analyst hit
me
don't build up to it hit me tell me
something and then get out
leave them with something where they go
do you hear what fitzpatrick said that's
what you want and if i go through a show
and i don't remember anything you said
then you didn't do your job
yeah okay well thank you for that advice
i'll uh
we'll see how i do yeah
but you know
no reason to be nervous are you more
nervous about this than you were your
first start in the nfl
no the this part
i'm not going to say this part's going
to be easy but you know this is me
getting to watch football and talk about
football so you know we did our first
run through in a pre-season game uh two
weeks ago
and the part that i enjoyed most i got
to sit and watch the first half and then
put a clip together of trey lance
and four or five plays just to give
everybody my perspective on what i
thought and one of the first things i
thought the first play of the game
he kind of tripped up the running back
which maybe a lot of people didn't see
or noticed but
his mind was moving a little fast even
though it was a preseason game he hasn't
played a lot of games he was nervous and
so picking up on some of those little
nuances
that's kind of what got me going a
little bit as i was doing my stuff at
halftime was being able to see that
take my perspective and project it to
the eye and it's a great point you bring
up and i always use this rodney harrison
came in for an audition and he
he noticed that tony gonzalez lined up
one yard wider
and he said we always knew it was a pass
play and it was so small
but you want to make your audience
smarter and you have that ability with
all the years that you played different
places different coaches different
styles
uh different defenders to be able to
share that is is really what's essential
and and having that ability to pick up
on nuance is is what separates you know
average from good and good from great
so
and now now i'm working with tony
gonzalez so i'll see if there's any
tendencies he has probably
uh good luck ryan and uh thanks again
all the contributions you made over the
years to the show you're always
available we appreciated that and uh we
wish you well
all right get that prime video app let's
do it on thursday night football baby